Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. hello welcome to the rest is history's london week so we've had um on monday we had a tour around roman london yesterday we were looking at uh two london places and today dominic we are looking at two figures who have lived in london who are part of the fabric of London's history. And you are kicking us off, aren't you? So who have you chosen? Well, the thing about Londoners, Tom,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》伦敦周节目。周一的时候，我们游览了罗马时期的伦敦；昨天，我们探讨了伦敦的两个地方；而今天，多米尼克，我们将聚焦两位曾在伦敦生活过的人物，他们是伦敦历史血脉的一部分。这一期由你来开场，对吧？那么你选择的是谁呢？好吧，关于伦敦人，汤姆，
is that most Londoners, or lots of Londoners, weren't born in London, were they? Is your Londoner... I don't want you to give away who your Londoner is. No, my Londoner was definitely not born in London. Wasn't even born in Britain, Dominic. Well, that's exciting. That is tantalising.
那就是大多数伦敦人，或者说很多伦敦人，其实都不是在伦敦出生的，对吧？你选的这个伦敦人……我可不想让你剧透你选的是谁。不，我的伦敦人绝对不是在伦敦出生的。甚至都不是在英国出生的，多米尼克。哇，那太令人兴奋了。真是吊人胃口。
So my London figure was actually born in Somerset in a place called Sharpham. I don't know where Sharpham is. Have you been to Sharpham, Somerset? No, if I have, I don't remember it. Very small village. And he was born in 1707, and his name is Henry Fielding. So he is the son of an officer, a military officer called colonel edmund fielding who had
所以，我选的这位伦敦人物实际上出生在萨默塞特一个叫做沙普姆（Sharpham）的地方。我不知道沙普姆在哪里。你去过萨默塞特郡的沙普姆吗？没有，如果我去过，我也记不得了。一个非常小的村庄。他出生于1707年，名字叫亨利·菲尔丁（Henry Fielding）。所以他是军队军官埃德蒙·菲尔丁（Edmund Fielding）中校的儿子，
fought under the duke of marlborough in the wars of the spanish succession and so on and um henry it's a quite well-off family uh henry grows up in somerset uh disaster strikes when he is 11 his mother dies and his father edmund the, the military man, is generally regarded as feckless. He's charming but feckless. So extraordinarily, Henry's grandmother sues his father for custody after the death of Henry's mum. And the grandmother wins. And Henry is taken away from his father
曾随马尔伯勒公爵参加过西班牙王位继承战争等等，然后呢，亨利，这是一个相当富裕的家庭，亨利在萨默塞特长大。然而灾难在他11岁时降临，他的母亲去世了，而他的父亲埃德蒙——那个军人——通常被认为是个不靠谱的人。他很有魅力，但很不靠谱。因此，令人匪夷所思的是，在亨利的母亲去世后，亨利的祖母起诉了他的父亲以争夺抚养权。最终祖母赢了。亨利被带离了他的父亲，
and given to his grandmother, who sends him to Eton. So that's what happens to young Henry. And at Eton, he becomes best friends or great pals with the future Pit the Elder, which is nice. So he's going up in the world. I mean, he doesn't know that Pit the Elder is going to be Pit the Elder. He just thinks of him as William, just some Billy Pitt or something, who loves the war game. to be Pitt the Elder. He just thinks of him as William, just some Billy Pitt or something, who loves the war game.
并交给了祖母，祖母把他送到了伊顿公学。这就是小亨利的人生轨迹。在伊顿公学，他与未来的老威廉·皮特成了挚友或极好的伙伴，这挺不错的。所以他正在平步青云。我是说，他当时并不知道老皮特以后会成为老皮特。他只是觉得他叫威廉，也就是某个叫比利·皮特之类的人，非常热爱战争游戏。成为老皮特。他只是觉得他叫威廉，也就是某个叫比利·皮特之类的人，非常热爱战争游戏。
And his tails. Yeah, exactly. They're having a tremendous time talking about Latin and playing obscure sports. Anyway, Henry Fielding's life takes an unexpected turn when he is about 18. He's obviously a sort of rambunctious young man. He has become infatuated with his cousin,
还有他的各种恶作剧。对，没错。他们度过了一段非常美好的时光，一起探讨拉丁语，玩一些冷门的运动。不管怎样，亨利·菲尔丁的生活在大约18岁时发生了意想不到的转变。他显然是一个有些桀骜不驯的年轻男子。他迷恋上了自己的表妹，
who's called Sarah. And one day when she's on her way to church he tries to kidnap her and run off with her and sarah's family are outraged by this behavior so henry has to flee abroad for a time um to escape prosecution so that sort of tells you something a bit about his personality so to give you a sense of um of him tom he is he's a huge man he's more than six feet tall which is very tall by the standards of the early 18th century um one of his friends says quote he was not a handsome man so um yeah you can draw your own conclusions um he's said to have joked with his friends about his nose and his chin. What was the joke?
名叫萨拉。有一天，当她去教堂的路上时，他试图绑架她并带着她私奔。萨拉的家族对这种行为感到无比愤怒，因此亨利不得不暂时逃往海外，以逃避起诉。所以这大致反映了他的一些性格特点。为了让你对他的外表有个概念，汤姆，他是个身材高大的男子，身高超过六英尺，在18世纪初的标准来看这非常高。他的一个朋友曾说：“他不是一个长相英俊的男子。”所以，好吧，你可以得出自己的结论。据说他曾和朋友开玩笑谈论自己的鼻子和下巴。什么玩笑？
I think the joke was they were quite large. They're over large. But he's a very warm and sociable sort of man. Well, he's a very funny man as well, isn't he? Yeah. One of his friends said of him, he had more wit and humour than Swift, Pope and the other wits of his time put together. Because did he end up writing a very famous novel that then became... He did. I'm going to come to that because he's a man of great
我想这个玩笑是说它们相当大。大得过头了。但他是一个非常热情、合群的人。嗯，他也是一个非常有趣的人，对吧？是的。他的一个朋友评价他说：“他的机智和幽默超过了斯威夫特、蒲柏以及他那个时代其他所有机智之人的总和。”因为他后来写了一部非常著名的小说，后来变成了……是的。我马上要讲到这一点，因为他是一个充满
appetites and passions. So he loves food, he loves drink, he loves snuff. He's a great snuff addict and he loves the pleasures of the bedroom. So he's lusty. He's a lusty 18th century fellow. And he starts off, he decides he wants to be a writer. So he's lusty. He's a lusty 18th century fellow.
食欲和激情的人。所以他爱美食，爱美酒，爱鼻烟。他是个狂热的鼻烟迷，并且热爱闺房之乐。所以他精力旺盛。他是一个18世纪精力充沛的家伙。他一开始，决定自己想成为一名作家。所以他精力旺盛。他是一个18世纪精力充沛的家伙。
And he starts off, he decides he wants to be a writer. So he comes to London, sort of hanging around London with other wits and coffeehouse people and stuff. Rub Street. Exactly. He writes plays which satirise Walpole, who's the first prime minister. Jonathan Wilde, isn't it?
他一开始，决定自己想成为一名作家。因此他来到伦敦，和别的机智之士以及咖啡馆里的人混在一起。格拉布街（Grub Street）。没错。他写剧本讽刺沃波尔，也就是第一任首相。还有乔纳森·维尔德（Jonathan Wilde），对吧？
Is that right? Exactly. The big cheese of the day. So Jonathan Wilde is about a thief taker, isn't it? Is that right? Exactly. The big cheese of the day. So Jonathan Wilde is about a thief taker, isn't it? And Jonathan Wilde is a kind of metaphor for Walpole in this. So his plays are sort of censored and he's slightly frowned upon.
是这样吗？没错。当时的大人物。所以《乔纳森·维尔德》讲的是一个捕贼人的故事，对吧？是这样吗？没错。当时的大人物。所以《乔纳森·维尔德》讲的是一个捕贼人的故事，对吧？而剧中的乔纳森·维尔德某种程度上就是沃波尔的隐喻。因此他的剧本遭到了某种程度的审查，他也因此略受非议。
He ends up he moves into books because he writes, the big book of the day is a book called Pamela. Sort of a pistolry novel. One of the first, if not the first, novels in English. Samuel Richardson. Samuel Richardson.
他最终转向了图书创作，因为他写了当时的一本大热书籍，叫做《帕梅拉》（Pamela）。一种书信体小说。可以说是英语小说中的第一批，如果不是第一部的话。塞缪尔·理查森（Samuel Richardson）。塞缪尔·理查森。
And it's a very improving, sort of morally serious kind of book, as all Richardson's books are. So Henry Fielding writes a spoof of it, a parody called Shamala, and that's very successful. So he writes more books. He does one about supposedly her cousin, doesn't he? Joseph Andrews. Yeah, exactly.
这是一本非常具有教育意义、某种程度上道德严肃的书，正如理查森所有的书一样。所以亨利·菲尔丁写了一部恶搞它的作品，一部名为《夏美拉》（Shamala）的讽刺小说，获得了巨大的成功。于是他写了更多书。他写了一本据说是关于他表弟的书，对吧？《约瑟夫·安德鲁斯》（Joseph Andrews）。对，没错。
And then at the end, it starts in the 1740s, and then the end of the decade ends with him writing his masterpiece, Tom Jones. So Tom Jones is, for people who don't know, that is a book that everybody should read, an absolutely uproarious, rambustious, really fun book, brilliantly written, sort of picaresque. Tom Jones has all these adventures across the country.
然后到了最后，时间进入18世纪40年代，那个十年代的末尾以他创作的杰作《汤姆·琼斯》（Tom Jones）而告终。所以对于不知道的人来说，《汤姆·琼斯》是一本每个人都应该阅读的书，一本绝对令人捧腹、生气勃勃、极其有趣、文笔精妙的流浪汉体小说。汤姆·琼斯在全国各地经历了种种冒险。
Who's the squire? Squire Weston. Squire Weston. Very like you. Like me. Grumpy. Miserable. Yeah, but he's a kind of honest man. Lives in the country. Has no time for London. Yeah, that's right. Writes columns for the Daily Mail. All that kind of stuff.
那个乡绅是谁？韦斯顿乡绅（Squire Weston）。韦斯顿乡绅。非常像你。像我。暴躁。痛苦。是的，但他是个某种程度上诚实的人。住在乡下。对伦敦没兴趣。对，没错。给《每日邮报》写专栏。诸如此类的事情。
I thought of myself as Tom Jones in that. I'm afraid not, Dominic. I'm afraid not. And then there's a sinister schoolmaster, isn't there, called Thwackham? That's it, exactly. Yes. I think it is Mr. Thwackham, isn't it?
我还以为自己在那种情况下就像汤姆·琼斯呢。恐怕不是，多米尼克。恐怕不是。然后还有一个阴险的学校校长，对吧，叫思韦克姆（Thwackham）？正是如此，没错。是的。我想是思韦克姆先生，对吧？
Tom Jones is always, he basically travels across the country falling in and out of people's beds, leaping out of the windows of inns. Eating oranges. Yeah. In a lasci Eating oranges. Yeah. In a lascivious way. Exactly. And this was made into a film in the 1960s,
汤姆·琼斯总是，他基本上是在全国各地旅行，不断进出别人的床铺，从客栈的窗户跳出来。吃橘子。对。以一种好色的方式。吃橘子。对。以一种好色的方式。没错。这部作品在20世纪60年代被改编成了电影，
1963, I think, with Albert Finney. Absolutely tremendous sort of 60s film. I mean, it looks quite dated now because it uses all sort of 60s gimmicks. Technicolor. Yeah. Anyway, he goes into the law. So he's involved with the law
我想是1963年，由阿尔伯特·芬尼（Albert Finney）主演。绝对是一部极了不起的60年代电影。我是说，现在看来它显得相当过时了，因为它运用了所有60年代的小把戏。彩色电影。对。不管怎样，他后来从事了法律工作。所以他卷入了法律界，
and this comes about because he's a fanatical anti-Jacobite so he's a very staunch Anglican supporting the Hanoverians supporting the Hanoverians so when you have the 45
这是因为他是一个狂热的反詹姆斯党人，所以他是一个坚定支持汉诺威王朝的英国国教徒，支持汉诺威王朝。所以当发生45年
the sort of Bonnie Prince Charlie uprising he writes loads of stuff for the government saying Bonnie Prince Charlie is a terrible fellow, hurrah for the Hanoverians, all this. And as a result of this, he is appointed as basically London's chief magistrate. And this is really his claim to fame, specifically as a Londoner. Because London in the 18th century has expanded colossally um so loads of sort of what were previously sort of the rural fringes of london have been filled in and are now absolutely teeming with people with crime with poverty it's a place like covent garden is the sort of classic example um Gin Lane is the Hogarth cartoon.
即邦妮·普林斯·查理（Bonnie Prince Charlie）起义时，他为政府写了大量文章，说邦妮·普林斯·查理是个糟糕的家伙，汉诺威王朝万岁，诸如此类。正因如此，他被任命为伦敦的首席治安法官。这可以说是他最声名显赫的地方，尤其是作为一名伦敦人。因为18世纪的伦敦急剧扩张，所以很多以前属于伦敦乡村边缘地带的地方都被填满，现在到处挤满了人、充斥着犯罪和贫困，像考芬园（Covent Garden）就是典型的例子，而荷加斯的漫画里则有《金酒巷》（Gin Lane）。
Yeah, so Gin Lane, if you think of Hogarth's cartoons, are sort of people falling out of windows and, you know... Dropping their babies down. Exactly, on the streets. The sort of fear of the London mob and all of that sort of stuff. So this is partly what Fielding's job is to kind of deal with. And one reason that it's been very difficult to deal with this is London obviously has no
对，所以《金酒巷》，如果你想起荷加斯的漫画，那就是人们从窗户里摔出来，你知道的……把婴儿掉在地上。没错，掉在大街上。那种对伦敦暴民的恐惧以及诸如此类的情绪。所以这也是菲尔丁的工作在某种程度上需要应对的。而之所以很难应对这一点的一个原因，显然是伦敦没有
police force. So it basically has a system of volunteer constables who are completely useless. But it also has a system of, you mentioned Jonathan Wilde, of thief-takers. So the thief-takers are utterly corrupt. They basically will solve, if you're the victim of
警察部队。所以它基本上采用的是完全没用的志愿治安员制度。但它也有一套制度，你刚才提到了乔纳森·维尔德，也就是捕贼人制度。所以这些捕贼人极其腐败。基本上，如果你是轻微犯罪的受害者，
petty crime, the thief-takers will solve it for a fee. So you pay them, basically. Like bounty hunters. They are, exactly. But they're in league often. I mean, often some of the big thief-takers, I mean, they're actually the heads of criminal gangs themselves.
捕贼人会为了报酬帮你破案。所以你付钱给他们，基本上是这样。就像赏金猎人一样。他们正是如此。但他们通常串通一气。我是说，通常一些最大的捕贼人，我的意思是，他们实际上自己就是犯罪团伙头目。
So they're basically prophets in every conceivable way. They'll rob you, and then they charge you to get your stuff back. It's intensely corrupt. So Henry Fielding, his office, the magistrate's court, they charge you to get your stuff back it's it's intensely corrupt yeah uh so henry fielding he his office the magistrate's court he's become the chief magistrate and his office is in bow street at number four bow street which is in the bedford estate near covent garden so this is quite a notorious red light district in the mid 18th century he's in the heart of it and he wants to um he wants to sort of sort it out now he's very forward thinking
所以他们基本上在所有可以想象的方面都是暴利谋取者。他们抢劫你，然后向你收费把你的东西赎回来。这极其腐败。因此，亨利·菲尔丁的办公室，也就是治安法官法院，他们向你收费把你的东西赎回来，这极其腐败，是的。所以亨利·菲尔丁，他的办公室，也就是治安法官法院，他成为了首席治安法官，他的办公室在鲍街（Bow Street）4号，位于靠近考芬园的贝德福德庄园（Bedford Estate），所以这是18世纪中期一个相当臭名昭著的红灯区。他身处其中，并且他想要，他想要整顿一下。现在，他思想非常前瞻，
because at the beginning of the 1750s he writes a sort of blueprint called a proposal for making an effectual provision for the poor and he says basically what we should do is we should get thousands of poor londoners we should build a massive workhouse for them and that sounds grim but but wait for it in which we'll they'll be decently housed we'll teach them a trade um they'll get wages they'll pay them a little bit as they learn the trade and they'll be you know have lessons and they'll have religious services and all this stuff and they'll basically be rehabilitated and then we'll turn them out of the workhouse as useful citizens so it's basically a sort of Scandinavian prison. And obviously nobody listens. People think it's absolutely demented.
因为在18世纪50年代初，他写了一份类似蓝图的文件，题为《关于为穷人作出切实规定的提议》（A Proposal for Making an Effective Provision for the Poor），他在书中基本上表示，我们应该做的是，把成千上万的伦敦穷人集中起来，为他们建造一个巨大的贫民习艺所（workhouse），这听起来很严苛，但先别急，我们要让他们在里面有得体的住所，教他们一门手艺，他们会得到工资，当他们学习手艺时我们会付给他们一点钱，他们会有，你知道的，会有课程，会有宗教礼拜以及所有这些东西，他们基本上会被改造好，然后我们会把他们作为有用的公民释放出习艺所——所以这基本上算是一种斯堪的纳维亚式的监狱。显然没有人听取。人们觉得这完全是精神错乱。
Kind of woke Tosh. Woke Tosh. So that's ignored. But what is not ignored is his idea for police. So he has this idea of employing, instead of people
有点像觉醒派胡言（woke Tosh）。觉醒派胡言。所以这被忽视了。但没有被忽视的是他关于建立警察队伍的想法。所以他有这样一个想法：不再雇用私人捕贼人，
employing kind of private thief takers, he, as the magistrate, will employ a team of six highly skilled, trained men, crack men, who will work for him. He will send them out to raid robbers and highwaymen, to raid gaming houses, to charge off and apprehend villains and get people's property. So the six of them at first, they are each given handcuffs, a pistol, and a stick. They are given a guinea a week.
而是由他作为治安法官，雇用一队六名高度熟练、受过训练的精干人员，由精锐男子组成的小队为他工作。他会派他们去打击强盗和拦路强盗，突袭赌博场所，冲出去逮捕恶棍并追回人们的财产。所以这六个人一开始，每个人都拿到了一副手铐、一把手枪和一根棍子。他们的周薪是一个畿尼。
And basically, if they catch criminals, they get commission on top of that. And they're answerable to him. Does that not encourage them to, you know, fabricate evidence, say? No, they're absolutely unimpeachable. That is woke to us. Does that not encourage them to fabricate evidence, say? No, they're absolutely unimpeachable, Tom. That is woke to us, from you. I'm sorry to cast a spell on the Bay Street rumours. Yeah, why do you hate Britain, Tom?
基本上，如果他们抓住了罪犯，还能在此基础上获得提佣。而且他们直接对法官负责。这难道不会鼓励他们，你知道的，比如伪造证据吗？不，他们绝对无可挑剔。这就是我们的“觉醒派”作风。这难道不会鼓励他们伪造证据吗？不，他们绝对无可挑剔，汤姆。你这纯粹是把“觉醒”帽子扣在我们头上了。我很抱歉给鲍街的传言施了什么魔法。是啊，汤姆，你为什么讨厌英国？
I'm sorry. Maybe it does. I haven't come across it, but maybe if there are Bow Street runners, aficionados out there who know street runner truthers yes exactly so there's only six of them but this is a tremendous innovation i mean i know six doesn't sound like many but it does expand over time and what's the population of london at this point about a million yeah so i mean how many do you need
我很抱歉。也许吧。我没遇到过，不过也许如果有鲍街跑差（Bow Street Runners）的狂热爱好者在听，他们了解跑差的真相……对，没错，所以虽然只有六个人，但这绝对是一项重大的创新。我的意思是，我知道六个人听起来不多，但随着时间推移它确实在扩张。当时伦敦的人口是多少？大约一百万。对，所以——你觉得需要多少？
so it's kind of like marvel comics well within within 50 years or so tom there are 68 of them i mean come on yeah i mean that's loads so what's the difference between them and and what peel does that's a very good question i think they're just much less they're much less regulated they're quite informal they're answerable to the magistrate and they don't wear those kind of blue top hats they don't have any uniform at first. They wear their own clothes. So they're plain clothes. But the other thing that's really interesting
所以这有点像漫威漫画。好吧，在50年左右的时间里，汤姆，有68个人了。我是说，拜托。对，我的意思是，这已经很多了。那么他们和皮尔（Peel）建立的警察有什么区别？这是一个非常好的问题。我觉得他们受到的监管要少得多，相当非正式，直接向治安法官负责，而且他们一开始不戴那种蓝色的高顶礼帽，也没有任何制服。他们穿自己的便服。所以他们是便衣。但另一个非常有趣的事情是，
is that his brother, so he has a brother called John. And John was blinded at the age of 19 in a naval accident, the details of which he never divulged to the public. So he's been blinded mysteriously on a ship. We don't know why. Andged to the public. So he's been blinded mysteriously on a ship.
他的兄弟，他有一个兄弟叫约翰（John）。约翰在19岁时的一次海军事故中双目失明，事故的具体细节他从未向公众透露。所以他是在一艘船上神秘失明了。我们不知道原因。向公众透露。所以他是在一艘船上神秘失明了。
We don't know why. And John has the idea. He says, why don't we issue a sort of gazette, a police gazette that will have descriptions of criminals? And this is the first time they do it. So they basically send out, you know, wanted Tom Holland. Wearing a wig. Right.
我们不知道原因。而约翰有个主意。他说：“我们为什么不发行一种公报，一份包含罪犯体貌特征的警察公报呢？”这是他们第一次这样做。所以他们基本上发出通缉令，比如：通缉汤姆·霍兰德。戴着假发。没错。
You can't miss him. Yeah. All 18th century men look the same. So do you want to know what this was called? It was called The Quarterly Pursuit, the name of this gazette. But they decided that was a terrible name. So they renamed it, I think. I don't know whether this is a worse name or a better name.
你绝不会认错他。对。所有18世纪的男人看起来都一样。所以你想知道这叫什么名字吗？它被称为《季度追踪》（The Quarterly Pursuit），这就是这份公报的名字。但他们觉得这个名字太糟糕了。所以他们改了名，我想。我不知道这算是一个更糟的名字还是更好的名字。
They renamed it The Public Hue and Cry. That's a great name. So the Public Hue and Cry, you would buy that. It would have all the details about the latest theft. Horrible murders. Horrible murders, wanted suspects. High women. Yeah.
他们把它改名为《公众喧嚣与呐喊》（The Public Hue and Cry）。这是个好名字。所以《公众喧嚣与呐喊》，你会买一份来看。上面会有关于最新盗窃案的所有细节。可怕的谋杀案。可怕的谋杀案，通缉嫌疑人。拦路强盗。对。
Do you know, how come no one has made a kind of... A rollicking series? You shouldn't have given it away, Tom, because we now can't... Yeah, we can. We can. Do you think? Yes. We could do the rest is history productions.
你知道吗，为什么没有人拍一部那种……一部热闹欢快的电视剧？你不该剧透的，汤姆，因为我们现在不能……不，我们可以。我们可以。你觉得呢？可以。我们可以制作“历史的余烬”出品。
Yeah. So if you're listening, if you're some sort of TV producer with horrible glasses... They don't have to wear horrible glasses. But they do, though. They do. No, they don't. We both know that they do. No.
所以如果你在收听，如果你是什么带着一副丑陋眼镜的电视制作人……他们不一定非得戴丑陋眼镜。但他们确实戴啊。他们确实戴。不，他们不戴。我们俩都知道他们戴。不。
I think you're showing your age. I don't think they wear horrible glasses anymore. Don't they? No, you've been stuck in the Cotswolds too long. What do they wear? They don't wear glasses. They wear contact lenses. I don't think... Whatever.
我觉得你暴露了自己的年龄。我觉得他们现在不戴那种丑陋的眼镜了。是吗？不，你在科茨沃尔德（Cotswolds）呆得太久了。他们戴什么？他们不戴眼镜。他们戴隐形眼镜。我不觉得……随便吧。
What Dominic is saying is that... It's ours. We own this franchise. If you are listening and you're maybe working for Netflix, you've got an enormous amount of cash and you would like to commission us to produce The Public Hue and Cry, a scintillating tale of crime and detection in 18th century London,
多米尼克的意思是……这是我们的。我们拥有这个版权。如果你正在收听节目，而且也许在奈飞（Netflix）工作，手头有一大笔资金，并且想委托我们制作《公众大声疾呼》（The Public Hue and Cry）——一个关于18世纪伦敦犯罪与侦查的精彩故事，
you can just email us or something. I'll tell you what I'm going to do, Tom. I'm going to give away the end of season one. So at the end of season one, so Henry Fielding, who's been the star of the first season, there's been a few flashbacks to him trying to kidnap the heiress to him being witty his early life sometimes he talks about tom jones in kind of you know the more reflective scenes uh but towards the end of season one tragically as we reach the early 1750s so he hasn't actually been magistrate that long but the bow Bow Street Runners are dashing,
你们可以直接发电子邮件或者别的什么联系我们。汤姆，我跟你说我要怎么做。我要把第一季的结局剧透了。所以在第一季的结局里——亨利·菲尔丁（Henry Fielding）一直是第一季的主角，剧里有一些闪回镜头，讲述他试图绑架女继承人、展现他的机智以及早年生活，在一些比较深沉的场景中，他有时会谈到《汤姆·琼斯》（Tom Jones）——但在第一季快结束时，悲剧发生了，时间来到了18世纪50年代初。虽然他当治安官其实没多久，但鲍街巡警（Bow Street Runners）
you know, all six of them around the metropolis. Henry Fielding gets dropsy. This is awful. So dropsy is a sort of apparently a cirrhosis of the liver. According to the Oxford Dictionary of National Biography, it says his skin was jaundiced, his body emaciated, his abdomen grotesquely bloated with water
你知道的，全城总共也就六个人，正在四处奔波。亨利·菲尔丁得了水肿病。这太可怕了。所以水肿病显然是一种类似于肝硬化的疾病。根据《牛津国家人物传记大词典》记载，上面说他的皮肤呈黄疸色，身体消瘦，腹部因积水而肿胀得不成人形，
that had to be tapped at frequent intervals. So, I think Netflix... That would be a shocking development. But it would provide great scope for a good actor. A very good actor. Yeah, Liam Neeson. Liam Neeson. Yes. He'd look good with
必须经常抽水。所以，我觉得奈飞……那将是一个令人震惊的发展。但这会给一个好演员提供巨大的发挥空间。一个非常优秀的演员。对，利亚姆·尼森（Liam Neeson）。利亚姆·尼森。是的。他演起……
Dropsy. He would. He'd act it well. So do you know what he does when he gets Dropsy and he knows that the game is up he doesn't get cured he doesn't get cured he goes to Portugal doesn't he so the final scenes there's location filming involved so that's the Christmas special so he ends up in Portugal and he dies in Lisbon in 1754.
水肿病来肯定很有型。他确实很适合。他会演得很棒。你知道他得了水肿病、知道大势已去时他做了什么吗？他没有去治病，他没有去治病，他去了葡萄牙，对吧？所以最后的场景涉及实地拍摄，那是圣诞特别篇，最后他于1754年在里斯本去世。
And he's buried there in the English cemetery in Lisbon. So later, I mean, this probably won't be in the Netflix series, in a Kingsley Amis novel, the plot slightly revolves around the fact that the character, a thinly veiled version of Kingsley Amis, has been invited to Lisbon to deliver some sort of Henry Fielding lecture. But in season two, Tom, we move to John Fielding, his brother, who you may remember. The blind one. Yes.
他被安葬在那里，即里斯本的英国公墓。所以后来——我的意思是，这大概不会出现在奈飞的剧集里——在一本金斯利·艾米斯（Kingsley Amis）的小说中，情节稍微围绕着这样一个事实展开：小说中的角色（一个金斯利·艾米斯的隐晦化身）被邀请到里斯本发表某种关于亨利·菲尔丁的演讲。但在第二季中，汤姆，我们将聚焦于约翰·菲尔丁（John Fielding），他的兄弟，你可能还记得。那个盲人。是的。
Whose nickname is the Blind Beak. The series writes itself. And he has a superpower. He's also a tremendous man. He founds an orphan for uh an orphan he founds an asylum for orphan girls in lambeth in your neck of the woods south london and he ends up being
他的绰号是“盲人比克”（The Blind Beak）。这部剧简直自带剧本。而且他有一种超能力。他也是一个了不起的人。他在兰贝斯（Lambeth）——也就是你所在的伦敦南部地盘——为孤儿创办了一所孤儿院，
knighted for it so he's an absolutely tremendous fellow but his power is that although he's blind he can recognize he can recognize three thousand criminals by the sound of their voices. That's amazing. That is a superpower. Because, you see, in my mind, rather like 18th century Londoners all looking the same, they all sound the same. Well, how do you think they sound?
为此他被册封为爵士。所以他绝对是个了不起的人物。但他的超能力是，尽管他双目失明，他却能通过声音辨认出三千名罪犯。太惊人了。这确实是超能力。因为你看，在我的想象中，就像18世纪的伦敦人看起来都长得一样一样，他们听起来也都一样。好吧，你觉得他们听起来是什么样的？
Oh, Mr. Fielding. I don't know. How does that? God bless you. That's Victorian. A Bow Street runner. Oh, the runners are after me, Tom. The Bow Street runners.
哦，菲尔丁先生。我不知道。那是怎样的？上帝保佑你。那是维多利亚时代风格的。一个鲍街巡警。哦，巡警在追我呢，汤姆。鲍街巡警。
Cue and cry. Yeah. Anyway, this is going to be a great series. So series season one is Public Cue and Cry. And then the series season two is public hue and cry and then the um the series season two is the blind yeah yeah um well that's i think i think future series well there's two seasons in it definitely yeah there's emery fielding then there's the blind beak i think i don't know do we we need to have to be chained to what actually happened no i mean it mean, it's kind of Peaky Blinders, wasn't it?
大声疾呼。对。不管怎样，这会是一部伟大的剧集。所以第一季是《公众大声疾呼》。然后第二季是《公众大声疾呼》，然后呢……第二季是……盲人……对，对，嗯……我觉得，我觉得未来的剧集——里面绝对有两季的内容，对吧？先是亨利·菲尔丁，然后是“盲人比克”。我觉得，不知道，难道我们必须被真实发生的历史所束缚吗？不，我的意思是，这有点像《浴血黑帮》（Peaky Blinders），不是吗？
Exactly. So I think by the time you get to season three, it's a generational change. Charles James Fox is maybe a character because he'd be solving crimes with Pitt the Younger. That'd be great, wouldn't it? Yeah. I mean, the 18th century is really, it's absent from our screen.
没错。所以我觉得到了第三季，就会迎来世代交替。查尔斯·詹姆斯·福克斯（Charles James Fox）可能会成为一个角色，因为他可以和小皮特（Pitt the Younger）一起破案。那一定很棒，对吧？是的。我的意思是，18世纪在我们的荧幕上确实是缺失的。
Dr. Johnson is solving crimes. You know what it is, Tom? We've had a previous episode about Dr. Johnson dealing with ghosts. Yes. Remember? Yeah, so he's ghostbusting. Ghostbusting. Yeah.
约翰逊博士（Dr. Johnson）在破案。你知道是怎么回事吗，汤姆？我们之前有过一期关于约翰逊博士处理幽灵的节目。对。记得吗？对，所以他在捉鬼。捉鬼。对。
Fabulous. Johnson and Boswell are ghostbusting. I mean, there's so much to play with here. So much to play with. It's unbelievable. We haven't had an offer. So TV producers, please don't be offended by Dominic characterising you as wearing ludicrous glasses. Scrub that. Focus on the gold that is this rich seam of his documentary series.
太棒了。约翰逊和鲍斯韦尔（Boswell）在捉鬼。我的意思是，这里有太多可以发挥的地方了。有太多可以发挥的地方了。真是难以置信。我们还没接到邀约。所以各位电视制作人，请不要因为多米尼克把你们描绘成戴着滑稽眼镜的人而感到冒犯。划掉这个。专注于这座纪录片系列的丰富宝藏所蕴含的金矿吧。
You make this series, you can buy enough glasses to last you a lifetime. Okay, that's brilliant, Dominic. Great choice. Let's go to a break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. Let's go to a break. free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. So this probably, Tom, will be one of the last Rest Is History episodes we record because after this we will be leaving podcasting to concentrate on the blind but in the meantime to leave listeners um leave them something to remember us by
你们制作了这个系列，就能买到足够戴一辈子的眼镜了。好的，太精彩了，多米尼克。选得真好。我们进入广告时间。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。我们进入广告时间。免费收听独家番外并提前获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余音》。所以这大概会是，汤姆，我们录制的最后一期《历史余音》节目之一，因为在此之后我们将离开播客界，专注于盲人题材。不过在此之前，为了给听众们留点念想，
by telling us about your top Londoner well so I may have mentioned this before Dominic I live in Brixton yeah in South London so I wanted to choose someone who lives in Brixton. So Brixton's actually had quite a lot of famous people who've lived in it. So David Bowie, of course. Yep. John Major. Two very different men. Ken Livingston. Yeah.
跟我们讲讲你最喜欢的伦敦人吧。好吧，我之前可能提到过这一点，多米尼克，我住在布里克斯顿（Brixton），位于伦敦南部。所以我想选一个住在布里克斯顿的人。其实布里克斯顿住过很多名人。比如大卫·鲍伊（David Bowie），当然。没错。约翰·梅杰（John Major）。两个截然不同的人。肯·利文斯顿（Ken Livingston）。对。
Clive Dunn, who was Corporal Jones in Dad's Army. Most of these people mean absolutely nothing to our overseas listeners. Well, David Bowie would. I'm sure most people have heard of John Major. And everyone's heard of John Major. Prime Minister. Yeah.
克里夫·邓恩（Clive Dunn），他在《老爹的军队》（Dad's Army）里饰演琼斯下士。这些人对我们的海外听众来说绝对毫无意义。好吧，大卫·鲍伊还是有的。我相信大多数人都听说过约翰·梅杰。而且人人都听说过约翰·梅杰。首相。对。
Top Brixton-born Prime Minister. So in London, there's this thing where you have blue plaques, which mark the houses of where famous people lived. And there are three blue plaques in Brixton. So one of them is Dan Lino, who's a musical artist. Yes, musical. Very famous. lino who's a musical artist yes musical very famous uh who um peter sellers believed was communicating with him sort of psychically ether psychically he would occasionally when people
最著名的布里克斯顿出生首相。所以在伦敦，有一种蓝色饰牌（blue plaques），用来标记名人们住过的房屋。布里克斯顿有三块蓝色饰牌。其中一块是丹·利诺（Dan Lino）的，他是一位音乐厅艺人。是的，音乐厅艺人。非常著名。……利诺，他是一位音乐厅艺人，是的，音乐厅艺人，非常著名……彼得·塞勒斯（Peter Sellers）曾坚信他通过某种超心理学的以太方式与自己进行交流。他偶尔会在人们
would offer peter sellers a part they join a play inspector cluso again he would turn and he would mutter over his shoulder and he said what do you think think, Dan? Do you think I should do it? So Dan Enos is still with us. And Peter Aykroyd wrote a novel. And the Lion House Golem. Yeah. So there's obviously a kind of faint hint of the supernatural around him. That's exciting. And then there's Havelock Ellis, who lived on a house up Brixton Hill, which is where I
邀请彼得·塞勒斯出演某个角色时——比如再次出演电影里的侦探克卢索（Clinspector Clouseau）——他会转过身去，在肩后咕哝着说：“丹，你觉得怎么样？你觉得我该接吗？”所以丹·利诺至今仍陪伴着我们。彼得·阿克罗伊德（Peter Ackroyd）写过一本小说。还有《莱姆豪斯的Golem》（The Lion House Golem）。所以他周围显然有一种微弱的超自然色彩。真令人兴奋。然后是哈维洛克·埃利斯（Havelock Ellis），他住在布里克斯顿山上一栋房子里——也就是我
live, who was a sexologist. I was just about to say he was a sexologist, but I don't know anything about him other than that word. Well, he was a pioneering sexologist i was just about to say sexologist but i don't know anything about him other than that word well he was he was a pioneering sexologist what did he do no i'm a sexologist well there's another netflix series tom yeah we're absolutely on fire today okay yeah so he was Okay. So he was a pioneering sexologist. And then the third one is the man that I have chosen,
住的地方——他是一位性学家。我刚才正要说他是一位性学家，但我除了这个词之外对一无所知。好吧，他是一位先锋性学家……我刚才正要说性学家，但我除了这个词之外对一无所知。好吧，他是一位先锋性学家。他做了什么？不，我是一个性学家。好吧，又是一部奈飞剧集，汤姆。我们今天状态真是火热。好吧，对。所以他是一位先锋性学家。然后第三个人是我选择的这位，
who is C.L.R. James. Oh, that's a good choice. C.L.R. James. Well, you'd like him because he's a Marxist. Of course. He's actually a Trotskyist. He's a big, big fan of Trotsky. But the reason I like him is that he obsessed about cricket and wrote a book called Beyond the Boundary,
他就是C·L·R·詹姆斯（C.L.R. James）。哦，这个选择真不错。C·L·R·詹姆斯。好吧，你会喜欢他的，因为他是个马克思主义者。当然。他其实是个托派分子。他是托洛茨基的超级狂热粉丝。但我喜欢他的原因是他对板球痴迷不已，并写了一本名为《超越边界》（Beyond the Boundary）的书，
which is widely held to be not just the best book on cricket, but one of the best books on sport ever written. And he ended up in Brixton. He lived there for the last years of his life. But he was actually born in Trinidad. He lived most of his life outside London. But I don't think that that makes him any less legitimate as a choice for a Londoner. Because what you were talking about with Fielding coming from Somerset. Yeah. London has always been a place that attracts people who live outside London. And actually, you know, for most of London's history, it was that that inevitably fueled its growth because more people would die you know it was such a kind of lethal place that you needed people to arrive to keep
这本书被广泛认为不仅是最好的板球著作，也是有史以来最优秀的体育著作之一。他最终在布里克斯顿安度晚年。他生命的最后几年都住在那里。但他实际上出生在特立尼达。他一生大部分时间都在伦敦以外度过。但我认为这并不妨碍他成为一个合乎情理的伦敦人候选。因为正如你之前谈到菲尔丁来自萨默塞特郡那样。是的，伦敦一直是一个吸引伦敦以外的人前来居住的地方。事实上，你知道，在伦敦历史的大部分时间里，正是这种人口流入不可避免地推动了它的增长，因为会有更多的人死去——
the population stable let alone grow that that wasn't the case obviously by the 20th century but but London I guess for people growing up in the Caribbean I mean as we know from the wind rush um people and and lots of people um lots of people coming to London from the Windrush, and lots of people coming to London from the Caribbean, they'd be processed in Clapham, and Brixton was the nearest area to Clapham where there was affordable housing. Yeah, because Brixton was slightly run down, wasn't it? Down a hill.
你知道，那是个相当致命的地方，你需要不断有人涌入来维持人口稳定，更不用说增长了。当然，到20世纪情况就不是这样了，但是伦敦——我想对于在加勒比地区长大的人来说——正如我们从“温德拉赫特”号事件中所了解到的那样，人们……以及许多人……许多人乘“温德拉赫特”号来到伦敦，还有许多人从加勒比地区来到伦敦，他们会在克拉珀姆（Clapham）办理入境手续，而布里克斯顿就是离克拉珀姆最近、有经济适用房的区域。对，因为布里克斯顿稍微有点破旧，不是吗？顺着山坡往下。
And that's why cheap housing. So that's why in the years after the Second World War. So Brixton was a place that was associated with musical. And that's why Dan Lino lived there. and that's actually why john major's father lived there because john major's father operate lived in um in brixton um and because they were actors musicians all that kind of stuff they tended to live in in fairly grotty housing because they didn't get much money um and so that's why people from the caribbean were able to move in there so john major has a history of cricket. He does.
这就是为什么那里有廉价住房。所以这就是为什么在第二次世界大战之后的几年里。布里克斯顿是一个与音乐厅有关联的地方。这也是为什么丹·利诺住在那里。这也是为什么约翰·梅杰的父亲住在那里，因为约翰·梅杰的父亲曾在……住在布里克斯顿……而且因为他们都是演员、音乐家之类的人，往往只能住在相当破烂的房子里，因为他们挣不到多少钱，所以加勒比地区的人才得以搬进那里。所以约翰·梅杰和板球颇有渊源。他确实有。
It's very good. It's very good. And he's also written a history of the musical. And at the beginning of his history of the musical, there's a bit where his dad is. So John Major's father was quite old when he had him. And John Major's describing his father in sort of post-war Britain, I don't know, in the 50s, 60s or something. He's dying basically in some boarding house,
写得非常好。非常棒。他还写过一本音乐剧史。在他的音乐剧史开篇，有这样一个片段：他的父亲——约翰·梅杰有他的时候年纪已经挺大了。约翰·梅杰在描述他父亲在战后英国（不知道是50年代、60年代还是什么时候）的生活。他基本上是在某个寄宿公寓里奄奄一息，
in some upstairs room in a boarding house. John Major says, this succession of very old and very strange people trooping up the stairs. And they were all people who had been acrobats, conjurers and stuff in the 1890s or something, coming up to say their farewells to John Major's father. Extraordinary scene.
在寄宿公寓楼上的某个房间里。约翰·梅杰说，那一连串非常苍老、非常古怪的人踉踉跄跄地走上楼梯。而他们全都是曾在1890年代左右担任过杂技演员、魔术师之类的人，特地赶来向约翰·梅杰的父亲告别。极其震撼的场景。
Well, Brixton's still got that, you know, it's still a place full of clubs and all that kind of stuff. Yeah. So it's still, it's still very much an entertainment center. But James is actually born quite a long time before people start coming, before the wind rush, before people start coming to London from,
好吧，布里克斯顿现在仍然保留着那种特色，你知道的，它仍然是一个充满各种俱乐部之类地方的地方。是的。所以它依然、依然在很大程度上是一个娱乐中心。但詹姆斯出生得其实相当早，远在人们开始到来之前、在“温德拉赫特”号事件之前、在人们从……
from the Caribbean. So he's born in 1901 in Trinidad. He is kind of lower middle class, but very, very bright. So he wins a scholarship to Queen's Royal College, which is a very good school. He's highly intellectual, but he's also very, very good at sport. So he is he actually holds the the record for the high jump in Trinidad. I think to this day, two or I think to this day two or three years no two or three years but I mean he is a record breaker um but cricket is his main sport absolutely
加勒比地区来到伦敦之前。所以他于1901年出生在特立尼达。他的家庭背景大致是中产阶级偏下，但极其极其聪明。所以他赢得了女王皇家学院（Queen's Royal College）的奖学金，那是一所非常优秀的学校。他极具求知欲，但他也非常擅长体育。所以他……他实际上保持着特立尼达跳高纪录。我想直到今天——两三年……或者我想直到今天两三年……不，是两三年，我的意思是他是打破纪录的人，但板球才是他的主业，他绝对
loves it um and he's he's almost good enough to kind of break into the into you know first class cricket but not quite but he's very good friends with a cricketer who is a man called Leary Constantine who um great west indies great west indies cricketer and who gets um an offer to go and play in the lancashire leagues and the lancashire leagues kind of very very tough cricket um professional so he goes to um to live in a place called nelson in lancashire and james goes with him um and james by this point is very very um very very into marxism very into cricket so he sets up as a a cricket correspondent stroke marxist which is you know there have been many of those um so he takes a lot a lot of boxes um so he covers cricket in the summer and he hangs out with Marxist circles, Trotskyite circles.
热爱板球，而且他的水平几乎好到足以跻身……你知道的，一级板球联赛，虽然差了一点点。但他和一位板球运动员是非常好的朋友，那个人叫利里·康斯坦丁（Leary Constantine），他是西印度群岛的伟大球星、西印度群岛伟大的板球运动员，曾获得邀请去参加兰开夏郡联赛（Lancashire leagues）。兰开夏郡联赛的板球对抗非常非常激烈，属于职业级别。所以他去了兰开夏郡一个叫纳尔逊（Nelson）的地方生活，詹姆斯也跟着一起去了。詹姆斯到这个时候已经非常非常迷恋马克思主义，也非常迷恋板球，于是他以板球记者兼马克思主义者的身份出道——你知道，这样的人以前也有不少，所以他符合很多方面的特征——因此，他夏天报道板球，平日里则与马克思主义圈子、托派圈子混在一起。
And he ends up writing a book that's still very, very famous, incredibly readable, called The Black Jacobins. So that's about Toussaint Louverture, isn't it? And Haiti, and the revolution in Haiti. And that's sort of the definitive, or for many, for decades, it was the absolutely definitive account of the Haitian Revolution and of the sort of, yeah, that Toussaint Louverture and all that sort of stuff.
最终他写了一本至今仍然非常著名、极其可读的书，名叫《黑泽科宾派》（The Black Jacobins）。这本书讲的是杜桑·卢维杜尔（Toussaint Louverture），对吧？还有海地，以及海地革命。这可以说是——或者对许多人来说，在几十年里——关于海地革命以及杜桑·卢维杜尔等相关事物的绝对权威记述。
Well, it's a brilliant work of scholarship. It obviously comes from a position of it has a kind of real moral force, kind of real blaze of intellectual fire to it uh but it's just incredibly readable really readable um and actually um james had written a play on the same theme um in which uh paul robeson was in it paul robeson starred oh so i didn't know that so it was a theme he was very interested in for obvious reasons and then in 1938 he leaves britain he goes on a kind of speaking tour around the united states and while he's in the united states he pops over the border to mexico where he meets trotsky so he hangs out with trotsky and he also meets
好吧，这是一部 brilhante（精彩的）学术著作。它显然源于一种立场，带有一种真正的道德力量，有一种炽热的知识火焰……但它就是极其引人入胜，真的非常易读。实际上……詹姆斯还写过一部同名戏剧，保罗·罗伯逊（Paul Robeson）曾参演其中，保罗·罗伯逊担任主演。哦，我不知道这件事。所以这是一个他出于显而易见的原因而非常感兴趣的主题。然后在1938年，他离开英国，在美国展开了一场巡回演讲。当他在美国时，他顺便跨过边界去了墨西哥，在那里遇到了托洛茨基。所以他和托洛茨基混在一起，还遇到了
diego rivera and frida carlo so he's kind of hanging out in you know in these circles he's surely not talking to them about cricket. Well, I always wondered, did he talk to Trotsky about cricket? It's such a kind of tantalising idea. You should write a play about it or something. That'd be good, wouldn't it? A kind of Tom Stoppard type play. Or indeed a Netflix serial.
迭戈·里韦拉（Diego Rivera）和弗里达·卡洛（Frida Kahlo）。所以他当时就在这些圈子里活动。他肯定不是在跟他们谈论板球吧。嗯，我一直很好奇，他有没有跟托洛茨基聊过板球？这是一个多么诱人的设想啊。你应该以此写部戏剧什么的。那一定很棒，对吧？有点像汤姆·斯托帕德（Tom Stoppard）风格的戏剧。或者干脆拍成奈飞连续剧。
No, I think it's more kind of a Stoppard play at the National. It is. It's at the Royal Court. Diego Rivera, Frida Kahlo, Trotsky and CLR James. And it's all themed around cricket that'd be good anyway so he's so he's in America but he is obviously um not the kind of guy that in post-war America the authorities are particularly keen on yeah um and so they managed
不，我觉得这更像是斯托帕德在国家剧院上演的那种剧。没错。在皇家宫廷剧院（Royal Court）。迭戈·里韦拉、弗里达·卡洛、托洛茨基和C·L·R·詹姆斯。而且整个主题都围绕着板球——那一定很棒。总之，他在美国，但很显然，在战后的美国，他并不是当局特别待见的那种人，
to expel him on a charge that he's kind of you know visa problems that kind of thing so james uh he comes back to london uh then he goes to trinidad gets it back home uh and that's where he writes beyond a boundary his great masterpiece so beyond a boundary which i've never read tell me what's so great about beyond the boundary because it is seen as one of the absolutely great books about sport so it's a book about cricket, but it has the theme, what do they cricket know? Who only cricket know? Yeah.
因此他们设法以签证有问题等借口将他驱逐出境。于是詹姆斯回到了伦敦，然后又去了特立尼达，回到了故乡，正是在那里他写出了《超越边界》这部伟大的杰作。所以《超越边界》这本书我从来没读过，告诉我《超越边界》到底好在哪里，为什么它被视为关于体育的绝对伟大著作之一？因为它是一本关于板球的书，但它有一个主题：“只懂板球的人，懂得什么板球？”（What do they cricket know? Who only cricket know?）
Um, so it is also very much about the relationship of the Caribbean to Britain. It's about, um, the way that empire works. It's, it's essentially, I mean,
因此，它也在很大程度上探讨了加勒比地区与英国的关系。它探讨了帝国的运作方式，从本质上讲——
it's, it's one of the great works of, um, post-colonial literature. And James is to Britain what Frantz Fanon is to France. I remember when I read it when I was kind of 15 or something and was terribly struck about how Marxist it was and how edgy and daring. Then I read it again a few years ago. And what struck me was how incredibly conservative it is, actually, especially compared to Fanon. I mean, Fanon still seems unbelievably radical, whereas James is all about WG Grace and how much he loves Trollope and things like that.
它是后殖民文学的伟大作品之一。詹姆斯对英国而言，就像法兰兹·法农（Frantz Fanon）对法国一样。我还记得我大概15岁左右读这本书时，大受震撼，觉得它太马克思主义了，既前卫又大胆。后来前几年我又读了一遍。而最让我震惊的是，它其实是多么的保守，尤其是跟法农相比。我的意思是，法农至今读来仍旧激进得令人难以置信，而詹姆斯满篇都是关于W·G·格雷斯（WG Grace），以及他多么热爱特罗洛普（Trollope）之类的内容。
So it's kind of interesting. I mean, James was a genuine, you know, he was genuinely radical. He was a Trotskyite. Of course he was. One of the things I think that makes Beyond the Boundary great as a work of literature is that it's not just agitprop. There's a real tension there. There's so much about the British Empire that he hates, but he also kind of loves it. He loves the great literature.
所以这挺有趣的。我的意思是，詹姆斯是一位真正的……他确实是个地道的激进派。他是个托派。他当然是。我认为《超越边界》之所以能成为一部伟大的文学作品，原因之一在于它不仅仅是政治宣传画。其中存在着一种真正的张力。他对大英帝国有那么多憎恨之处，但同时他也某种程度上热爱它。他热爱伟大的文学。
And he loves England. loves england and he you know he he is the one who really enshrines grace as a a distinctively victorian hero one who who's not who's idolized by the victorians but who also challenges a lot about what we would think conventionally the victorian age is about so it's a very very rich book very complex book very very subtle book and and very um fascinating as a self-portrait as well because james is not a modest man. It's fair to say. I mean, he has a very, very kind of robust sense of his own worth.
他热爱英格兰。他……他正是那个真正将格雷斯尊为独具维多利亚时代特色英雄的人——一个不仅被维多利亚时代的人所偶像化，同时也挑战了我们对维多利亚时代传统认知的许多方面的人物。所以这是一本非常非常丰富、极其复杂、非常微妙的著作，同时作为一本自传也非常引人入胜，因为詹姆斯可不是一个谦虚的人。公平地说。我的意思是，他对自己的价值有着非常、非常强烈的自信。
And that's also part of the kind of the drama of what he's writing about. And he writes about Constantine as well, because Constantine went, you know, goes on to become, he serves in the British government during the war. He gets a peerage. I think he becomes the first,
这也是他所写作的内容中戏剧性的一部分。他写过关于康斯坦丁的事情，因为康斯坦丁在战争期间在英国政府服务，后来获得了一个贵族头衔。我想他成为了第一个，
he's the first black peer. So James is, you know, I mean, he's the first black peer um so so james is you know i mean he's he's at the heart of quite seismic events yeah and so james is he in brixton at this point when he's no so he's in trend but he gets expelled in fact briefly he gets imprisoned and then he gets expelled so he comes back to london now where's he going to go so by this point brixton has become the kind of the capital of black brit. And one of the guys who is kind of the leading figure in kind of intellectual circles in Brixton is C.L.R. James's nephew, who's a man I'm sure you've heard of, Darkus Howe. Of course, Darkus Howe. Very, very kind of impressive man.
他是第一个黑人贵族。所以詹姆斯，你知道的，我的意思是，他是第一位黑人贵族，所以詹姆斯，你知道的，我的意思是，他处于相当震撼的事件的核心。是的，那么詹姆斯，他当时在布里克斯顿吗？当他不在时，他在特立尼达，但他被驱逐了，实际上短暂入狱，然后被驱逐，所以他回到了伦敦。现在他要去哪里呢？到这个时候，布里克斯顿已经成为了黑人英国人的某种首都。在布里克斯顿知识分子圈子里算得上领军人物的其中一个人，就是C·L·R·詹姆斯的侄子，这个人的名字我相信你一定听说过，达卡斯·豪。当然，达卡斯·豪。非常非常令人印象深刻的一个人。
And he was still, when I moved to Brixton, you'd see him occasionally on the tube. He was a very impressive looking man and kind of incredible baritone voice. Very, very smart. And he got his uncle to come and live in Brixton. And Darkest How is in Brixton because he is the editor of a magazine called Race Today, which had been founded in the 70s. And I think originally it had been in Notting Hill and originally had been very much focused on decolonization in Africa. So particularly concerned with apartheid in South Africa and things like that. But then increasingly through the 70s had become interested in the way
当我搬到布里克斯顿的时候，你偶尔还会在地铁上看到他。他是一个外表非常引人注目的人，有着不可思议的男中音嗓音。非常非常聪明。他让他的叔叔来到布里克斯顿居住。达卡斯·豪之所以在布里克斯顿，是因为他是一本名为《今日种族》（Race Today）的杂志的主编，这本杂志创立于70年代。我想它最初在诺丁山，最初非常关注非洲的非殖民化。因此特别关注南非的种族隔离以及诸如此类的事情。但随后在整个70年代，它越来越对以下方式感兴趣：
that immigrants from the the commonwealth in britain so not just from the caribbean but from india and pakistan and so on how they were what what how they were settling into britain and what their what their relationship to britain should be and could be um and darkest how becomes the editor of this magazine and he moves it to brixton and he moves it to 165 railton road and railton road in the 1981 riots which erupt um black people in brixton against the police yeah and it's the totemic riot of 1981 whole of brixton goes up in flames front line isn't it the front and railton road is is called the front line yes so it's the kind of the center of the rioting so 165 railton road you know it's it's a potent place for a magazine devoted to issues of of race and uh questioning the fabrics of the british state and
来自英国联邦的移民，不仅来自加勒比海，还来自印度和巴基斯坦等等，他们是如何在英国定居的，他们与英国的关系应该是什么，可以是什么。达卡斯·豪成为了这本杂志的主编，他把它搬到了布里克斯顿，搬到了雷尔顿路165号。雷尔顿路在1981年的暴动中爆发了，布里克斯顿的黑人抗议警察，是的，这是1981年具有象征意义的暴动，整个布里克斯顿陷入了火海。前线，不是吗？雷尔顿路被称为前线，是的，所以它是暴动的中心。因此，雷尔顿路165号，你知道的，对于一本致力于种族问题并质疑英国国家结构等各种事情的杂志来说，这是一个充满潜力的（重要）地方，
all that kind of stuff and clr james comes and he he loves it um he he gives a lecture in in brixton just after the riots. And he finds it an exciting place to be. And so he says, could he stay? He's looking for somewhere to live. And so he moves in. He's in his 80s at this point. He moves into the very small flat directly above the offices of Race Today on Relton Road.
以及所有这类事情。C·L·R·詹姆斯来了，他非常喜欢这里。他在暴动后不久在布里克斯顿做了一场演讲。他发现这里是一个令人兴奋的地方。所以他问他能不能留下来？他正在寻找住处。于是他搬了进来。他当时已经80多岁了。他搬进了位于雷尔顿路《今日种族》杂志社办公室正上方的那间非常小的公寓里。
And so that's where he stays. For the rest of the 80s? Because he died at the end of the 80s didn't he yeah he dies at the end of the 80s 89 yeah and and so and you know it's kind of and so i walk past it regularly and i look up and i see the name of this this great man up there and it's fantastic but the the other reason i just wanted to mention him was that um i think that there is also something rather rather wistful about it, certainly for me, because I I moved to Brixton in 92. And the year before that, I went to the Oval to see the West Indies against England. And this was the famous match where both them failed to get his leg over.
这就是他住下来的地方。一直到80年代结束？因为他在80年代末去世了，不是吗？是的，他在80年代末去世，89年，是的。所以，你知道的，这有点……所以我经常从那里走过，我抬头看到这位伟人的名字就在那里，这太棒了。但我只想顺便提一下他的另一个原因，是因为我觉得这其中也有点伤感，至少对我来说是这样，因为我是92年搬到布里克斯顿的。就在前一年，我去了奥弗球场看西印度群岛对阵英格兰的比赛。这就是那场著名的比赛，双方都没能把腿迈过去（指击球失误），
They precipitated Brian Johnson and Jonathan Agnew. They kind of corpsed. And that was the match where Viv Richards, the great West Indies batsman, played. He actually had a kind of a bearing and a sense of dignity rather like Darkers Howe, actually. And great bowlers
他们让布赖恩·约翰逊和乔纳森·阿格纽大笑不止。那是维夫·理查兹（Viv Richards）这位伟大的西印度群岛 batsman（击球手）参赛的比赛。实际上，他有一种风度和尊严感，真的很像达卡斯·豪。还有伟大的保龄球手
like Courtney Walsh, Kirtley Ambrose. So it was a very, very powerful team. England actually won that match, which maybe served as a kind of signal that West Indies cricket was, West Indies had been the great power in cricket throughout the 80s. And perhaps this was a kind of a presentiment
像考特尼·沃尔什、柯特利·安布罗斯。所以这是一支非常非常强大的球队。英格兰实际上赢了那场比赛，这或许是一个信号，表明西印度群岛的板球运动……西印度群岛在整个80年代一直是板球运动的超级强权。也许这是一种预感：
of the fact that cricket in the Caribbean was about to go into decline. But it was, the Oval was absolutely heaving with people who'd come up from brixton it was a kind of i should think about half england supporters half west indy supporters it was really really kind of exciting thrilling pollulating sporting occasion and it made me think brixton might be a kind of great place to live because you know loads of cricket fans so we moved there the next year but but since then, cricket in the Caribbean has really gone into decline.
加勒比地区的板球运动即将走向衰落。但当时奥弗球场挤满了从布里克斯顿赶来的人，我觉得大概有一半是英格兰球迷，一半是西印度群岛球迷。这真的是一个非常非常激动人心、令人振奋的体育盛会，它让我觉得布里克斯顿可能是一个非常棒的居住地方，因为你知道，有大量的板球迷。所以我们第二年就搬到了那里。但从那以后，加勒比地区的板球运动真的开始走下坡路了。
And definitely cricket in Brixton is a dead thing now. You know, it's not really followed at all, partly because the only cricket ground in the whole of Lambeth, the borough of Lambeth, which Brixton is in, is the Oval. You know, there's no other cricket ground. The facilities are terrible. There are cricket nets in Brockwell Park, which are in a terrible state of disrepair.
而且布里克斯顿的板球运动现在绝对已经是一件死气沉沉的事情了。你知道，大家根本不怎么关注它了，部分原因是因为整个兰贝斯区（布里克斯顿所在的兰贝斯自治市镇）唯一的一座板球场就是奥弗球场。你知道，没有其他板球场了。这里的设施糟糕透了。布罗克韦尔公园里的板球网处于极其失修的糟糕状态。
There's just no, there are no facilities. I mean, it's not completely dead. So you've got Ebony Rainford-Brent, who's from Brixton, who played in the England women's team. So she's kind of very prominent voice in contemporary English cricket. But aside from that, it's really faded.
这里简直没有……没有设施。我的意思是，它并没有完全消亡。所以你有埃博尼·雷恩福德-布伦特（Ebony Rainford-Brent），她来自布里克斯顿，曾效力于英格兰女子板球队。所以她是当代英国板球界一个非常突出的声音。但除此之外，它真的已经褪色了。
And so when I see C.L.R. James's name on that blue plaque, it does make me slightly sad and so uh when i see clr james's uh name on that blue plaque it does make me slightly sad and wistful as well so um so that's why i chose him okay well you've been listening to the rest is cricket with uh yeah sorry no no tom that's a good choice because clr james is absolutely um the fact that he's not born in l and he comes as an immigrant, as a Caribbean immigrant, is part of a wider story isn't it? But also he is probably the Titanic figure in that sort of tradition
所以当我看到那块蓝色牌匾上写着C·L·R·詹姆斯的金字时，这确实让我感到有点难过。所以，呃，当我看到那块蓝色牌匾上写着C·L·R·詹姆斯的姓名时，这确实也让我感到有点难过和伤感，所以……这就是我选择他的原因。好的，好吧，你一直在收听《板球余音》（The Rest Is Cricket），我是……是的，抱歉，不，汤姆，这是一个很好的选择，因为C·L·R·詹姆斯绝对是……他不是在伦敦出生，而是作为一名移民，作为一名加勒比海移民来到这里，这是更广泛故事的一部分，不是吗？但同时他可能也是那个传统中的泰坦式人物，
of, it's a tradition of post-colonial writing but it's also that very, very, I mean in contrast with Fanon a French writer or a French influence writer probably wouldn't start look to to wrap it around
这个传统属于后殖民写作的传统，但它也非常非常……我的意思是，与法农（Fanon）这位法国作家或受法国影响的作家形成对比的是，他可能不会从以下角度开始着手：
the subject of cricket would they they would start with some yeah well they wouldn't do a peton they would do it
以板球为主题，对吧？他们会从某个……是的，好吧，他们不会从派通（Peton）开始，他们会从
with a series of abstract nouns about liberty or something Fanon is as French is French in the way that
一系列关于自由或某种类似概念的抽象名词开始。法农就像法国人那样，而
the CLR James is British yeah I mean they they both absolutely bear the stamp of
C·L·R·詹姆斯则是英国人，是的。我的意思是，他们俩都绝对带有他们出生的那个帝国的烙印。
the empires into which they were born. But I think that James's relationship to British culture is much more conflicted than Fanon's was, I think. Right. Okay. So we'll definitely be back tomorrow with another podcast about a walk, because we've done the walk, haven't we? It was a walk around Smithfield and about the history of kind of medieval early modern london very exciting walk that we did uh the point at which we were doing that walk my new shoes which were inappropriate so i was going to a function blood was spurting out through the leather i was in i was in absolute
但我认为詹姆斯与英国文化的关系比法农要复杂得多，我认为是这样的。对。好的。所以我们明天肯定会带着另一期关于散步的播客回归，因为我们已经走过那条路了，不是吗？那是一次环绕史密斯菲尔德（Smithfield）的漫步，了解中世纪和早期现代伦敦的历史。那是一次非常激动人心的漫步。在我们进行那次漫步的时候，我的新鞋不太合适，所以我去参加一个活动时，血液正从皮革里渗出来，我简直痛苦万分，
agony so as tom i say come on yeah you'll hear tom talking a lot and you won't hear anything from me but the odd kind of muffled groan. But actually, Dominic, you mentioned Dr. Johnson investigating ghosts. We have the cock lane ghost, so we go past that. We will be talking about ghosts tomorrow. Yes. Now, there may be a podcast on Friday.
所以我对汤姆说，‘来吧，是的，你会听到汤姆说很多话，而你除了偶尔发出的那种沉闷的呻吟声外，什么也听不到。’但事实上，多米尼克，你提到了约翰逊博士调查鬼魂。我们有科克兰鬼魂（Cock Lane ghost），所以我们会经过那里。我们明天会讨论鬼魂。是的。现在，周五可能还会有一期播客。
If there isn't, it's because we're working on the blind beak with Netflix. But if that doesn't work out, we will be back on Friday with a podcast about moments from London's history. In fact, pardon me, Tom, because our moments are so good.
如果没有，那是因为我们正在与网飞（Netflix）合作制作《盲喙》（The blind beak）。但如果行不通，我们会在周五回归，带来一期关于伦敦历史时刻的播客。事实上，原谅我，汤姆，因为我们的历史时刻太棒了，
I almost want the Netflix series not to work out. Well, maybe, who knows? There's a real element of tension and jeopardy in the next few days as you wait to discover whether the rest is history has come to an end and whether the blind beak has got the green light. And if it doesn't events we've chosen yeah and so we'll see you tomorrow bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com.
我甚至希望网飞的系列剧不要成功。好吧，也许，谁知道呢？在接下来的几天里，当你们等待发现《历史余音》是否已经走到尽头，以及《盲喙》是否获得了绿灯时，有一种真正的紧张和悬念感。如果没成功……我们选择的事件，是的，所以我们明天见，拜拜。感谢收听《历史余音》节目。如需获取早期抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐余音》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外番外剧集以及抢先购买现场演出门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。